dora forever
that their time has passed
thanks to handsome jack
pandora needs a new hero
i know that hero is you
apart from the excruciating pain this is
great i've been waiting for a mighty
sanctuary i will be your wife
[Music]
great
just let me get this door open and we'll
hunt ourselves
let me know if i'm gonna run into
anything
i'll just assume you didn't see that
even though knuckle dragger blindsided
me i know the way around this glacier i
bet you will find my eye and frostbite
crevasse
stick close to the robot he will help
you get off this glacier and into the
city of sanctuary that is the only place
you will be safe
squires
um
let's go if we don't get my eye back
we'll never get to sanctuary
apart to uh the ball
they say jack's drilling operations are
causing those earthquakes that or your
mom just got out of bed
you'll need that funny little robot's
help to reach sanctuary the last bastion
of the resistance against jack and the
only place you'll be truly safe
get to sanctuary
i guess
friend of friends
onward
hey kiddo jack here president of
hyperion
let me explain how things work here the
vault hunters show up vault hunter looks
for the new vault vault hunter gets
killed by me you see the problem here
you're still alive so if you could just
do me a favor and off yourself that'd be
great
thanks pumpkin
oh my eyes are switched back on
i see a tough looking minion and an
incredibly handsome robot which means
that whoever has my eye
is very close
[Music]
my god
sphincters i say that a lot when i'm
frightened got my eye
great now we just gotta find someone to
put it back into me much as i'm sure
you'd like to jam your fist into my
skull optic surgery
professionals my
oh
child's play
and open
intruders detected locking doors
well it was nice knowing you i hear
getting eaten alive by bully box isn't
such a bad way to go let me get that for
you
executing phase shift
you're welcome
perks of being an artificial
intelligence i'm networked into almost
everything on this planet
it's a long way to sanctuary please take
whatever you need for the journey ahead
let me know when you're ready to go meet
with sir hammerlight minion
you